Sì.
Un quantum circuit sarà l'unità di valore
per la tua attività; il qubit è l'unità di informazione
ma un circuit è l'unità di computazione
quindi proviamo a capire cos'è un quantum circuit
e vediamo la sua anatomia
ecco come appare un quantum circuit
si compone di parti: i qubit
sono rappresentati da queste linee orizzontali; in questo caso stiamo rappresentando
un circuit che ha quattro qubit, come puoi vedere
qui mostrati; ora i gate sono
il modo in cui controlliamo i qubit
e si leggono i gate da sinistra a destra
e i gate a qubit singolo possono essere singoli
gate a qubit singolo o gate a qubit multipli
vedi lì il gate controllato
è quello che ha la linea tra due dei qubit
ed è lì che avverrà l'operazione di entanglement
e infine hai la misurazione e l'output classico
e cosa molto importante: esegui un circuit molte volte
per ottenere il risultato con il concetto di shots
e quindi uno shot counter, che è il numero di volte
in cui devi ripetere una computazione per ottenere il risultato
bene
come appaiono?
vediamo com'è un gate a due qubit
quello era l'immagine di prima, giusto: introduce un cambiamento di fase
e ho mostrato prima un'operazione che eseguiva quella rotazione
che permette di fare quell'operazione di interferenza
quindi facciamo un confronto tra un circuit classico
e un quantum circuit; in un circuit classico quello che
noti qui è che non vedi lune blu, giusto?
non ci sono rotazioni, tutto qui è rosa
e hai gli stati singoli
che in questi gate vedevamo comparire
ma nota che contrasto ci sarà
quando implementiamo effettivamente un quantum circuit
questi sono i circuit reali che eseguiamo nei nostri computer quantistici
che puoi provare anche tu
i circuit che andremo a creare
con la combinazione dei gate
generano la piena ampiezza complessa
dell'immagine che ti ho mostrato
prima; perché è importante?
perché ora possiamo generare queste relazioni complesse
tra i qubit in termini di fasi
ed entanglement, e poi attraverso l'atto della misurazione
siamo in grado di collassare questa enorme quantità
di computazione che sta avvenendo all'interno in
una risposta importante
ed è così che arriviamo finalmente a
alla risposta; quindi mettiamoli fianco a fianco, solo visivamente
puoi intuire che un circuit classico non può
mai sfruttare il vasto spazio computazionale
che può sfruttare un quantum circuit
è la visualizzazione migliore che ti dà questa intuizione
della ricchezza con cui possiamo accedere a questo grande stato.
E la parte bella di questo è che possiamo
avere molte classi di circuit per
svolgere funzioni diverse; quindi
per esempio questo è un circuit
progettato per modellare il rischio finanziario
questo è un esempio di circuit
usato per problemi di ricerca e ottimizzazione
e questo è un esempio di circuit usato per
simulare una molecola; un punto
importante da ricordare è che puoi progettare circuit diversi
per applicazioni diverse
i circuit che progettiamo vengono poi catturati
nel software e conservati come software
e nel nostro caso li conserviamo in Qiskit
che è il nostro kit di sviluppo open source per il quantum computing
questo è uno dei framework software più diffusi
per il quantum computing
e puoi immaginare di costruire
librerie di circuit che vengono incorporate in
programmi classici che ora combinano il meglio della programmazione classica
e il meglio della potenza quantistica